PERFECTION LINE TO START AND
THAT IS WHAT THE OFFICIAL
SCORERS A HALF-HOUR BEFORE THE
GAME, THAT, I OTHER NIGHT,
CLOSE TO A LINE C C BREAK THERE.
MICKEY: AND NAMESTNIKOV WAS
COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED AND SO
TOO COULD THIS ONE HERE
THE BRUINS SEND IT BACK IN.
CHORUSTER, WITH A LOT OF GUYS
LOOKING ON
WINNING THIS ONE, THE PUCKLIGNO.
CARLO HOLDING IT N LOOSE IN
FRONT,UCK
AND THAT HITS A SKATE AND IT WAS
BLOCKED BY ERNE, RECOVERED BY
THE LOOSE, THAT TIME RIGHT TO
SMITH WHO
KEN: BERGERON, LOOK,
WATCH WHAT HE DOES, ARE 0-ON THR
MICKEY: VERY GOOD CHECKED AND
LEAVE FOR HRONEK,HE
BRUINS TAKETRNAK
DUMPED IT OUT AND NOW SEIDER,
BACK THIS TIME TO RETRIEVE IT I.
SUTER BACKING HIM UP.
HAS TIME NOW FOR ]
[ CHEERING AND APPLAUSE ]
MICKEY: AND IN SPITE
MICKEY: YOU KNOW THAT BOSTON IS
VERY,
ZADINA, BACK FOR MANAGER
AND THE CANUCKS OF 73s COMING TR
RIGHT THERE.IND THE
JUST THREW HIS WEIGHT INTO
NAMEME LEAD,
233 TIMES THEY'VE LOST JUST TWO
WINNING NINE STRAIGHT AGAINSTL.
MARC STAAL IN THE CORNER, ITO PY
WHEN YOU HAVE THE BRUINS, ENDINN
FRONT OF THE AND THE RED
WINGS, TWO OF THE FOUR POWER
PLAYS THEY HAD NO SHOTS ON GOAL